Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous entendez ?
Hmmm... Il y a de l'orage dans l'air.
Je n'aime pas trop ça. Et vous ?
On dit que dans une telle situation,
il ne faut pas rester sous un arbre ni ouvrir un parapluie.
Alors, est-ce vraiment dangereux ?
Quel comportement faut-il adopter pour se protéger ?
Aujourd'hui, je réponds à toutes les questions que vous
vous posez sur les orages dans l'atelier.
Oh, j'ai senti une goutte.
Ne restons pas là,
ça va nous tomber sur la tête.
Savez-vous en quelle saison il y a le plus d'orages en France ?
On compte en moyenne 453000 impacts de foudre par an dans notre pays.
Mais c'est au mois de juillet et d'août,
quand il fait le plus chaud, qu'ils sont le plus nombreux.
Le record en une journée, le 6 août 1999 :
60335 éclairs
entre les nuages et le sol dans toute la France.
Ce qui impressionne le plus quand il y a de l'orage,
ce sont les éclairs.
Comment se forment-ils ?
Un orage éclate lorsque l'air est chaud et humide
et que le ciel se charge d'énormes nuages sombres
qu'on appelle les cumulonimbus.
Ce sont de véritables monstres.
Ils peuvent s'élever jusqu'à 15000 mètres d'altitude
et ils sont capables d'aspirer
9000 tonnes d'eau par seconde.
C'est à l'intérieur
ou à partir de ces nuages que les éclairs vont se former.
Tout cet air humide qui a pris de l'altitude laisse
forcément un vide que d'autres masses d'air,
souvent humides elles aussi, s'empressent de remplacer.
À l'intérieur du cumulonimbus,
l'air monte très vite. En prenant de l'altitude,
l'eau avec le froid se transforme en cristaux.
Ces cristaux s'agglomèrent et forment des grains de grésil
de plus en plus gros qui,
une fois trop lourds, tombent. Dans leur descente,
ils croisent et heurtent d'autres
grains de grésil tout juste formés qui, eux, sont en pleine ascension.
Les collisions provoquent un transfert de charges électriques.
Durant leur chute, les grains de grésil arrachent des électrons,
des charges négatives, aux grains qui montent
qui, du coup, deviennent positifs.
Ainsi, la base du cumulonimbus se charge négativement
tandis que le sommet accumule des charges positives.
Le cumulonimbus, vous le voyez, devient alors
une sorte d'énorme pile électrique,
avec un pôle positif là-haut et un pôle négatif à la base.
Quand la différence de potentiel est trop importante
entre la base et le sommet, le courant passe en générant
un éclair à l'intérieur du nuage.
On appelle ça des éclairs intra-nuageux.
Quand deux cumulonimbus sont relativement proches,
ça peut aller jusqu'à une centaine de kilomètres,
il peut y avoir des éclairs entre les deux.
On les appelle des éclairs inter-nuageux.
La tension d'un éclair peut atteindre 100 millions de volts
et une température de 30000 degrés.
Oui, mais moi, ce qui me fait peur,
c'est la foudre qui s'abat sur le plancher des vaches.
J'y viens.
En temps normal, d'un point de vue électrique,
le sol est neutre, c'est à dire qu'il y a autant de charges négatives que de charges positives.
Maintenant, il faut savoir que dans la nature,
les charges électriques de même signe se repoussent,
comme lorsque l'on approche les deux pôles identiques d'un aimant.
La base du nuage est à moins de 2000 mètres du sol.
C'est suffisant pour que les charges négatives présentes dans le sol soient repoussées
par les charges négatives présentes à la base du nuage.
Une zone chargée positivement se forme alors sous le nuage.
Là encore, une différence de potentiel s'installe
entre la base du nuage et le sol.
Et quand elle devient trop importante, un courant électrique se fraie un passage entre les deux bornes.
C'est la foudre.
Alors souvent, on entend dire que la foudre peut s'abattre n'importe où.
C'est vrai, mais le relief y est quand même pour quelque chose.
Les charges électriques ont tendance à s'accumuler
au niveau des points saillants : des clochers, des pylônes,
la cime des arbres.
La foudre va donc s'abattre sur ces pointes
parce que le chemin est plus court et parce qu'elles sont plus chargées.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet de pointe.
Alors, quand l'orage se déclenche,
il vaut mieux s'éloigner de ces points
hauts et saillants, pas tenir un parapluie ouvert
ou un autre objet métallique.
Si j'étais toi, je ne resterais pas sous cet arbre
avec ton parapluie.
Si un orage éclate, n'attendez pas.
Aux premiers signes visuels ou sonores,
mettez vous à l'abri. Si vous êtes coincé à l'extérieur,
n'allez surtout pas vous réfugier sous un arbre,
effet de pointe.
Mais ne restez pas non plus planté comme une tige
effet de pointe également.
Non, accroupissez-vous et serrez les pieds comme ceci.
Là, c'est sûr, je serre les fesses.
Quand la foudre s'abat sur le sol, un courant électrique
très puissant circule dans celui-ci.
Si quelqu'un se trouve sur le passage du courant,
il y a de fortes chances qu'il fasse un détour par son organisme.
Les tissus humains sont bien meilleurs conducteurs
que le sol d'une prairie.
Le courant rentre par un pied, circule
dans l'organisme et ressort par l'autre.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet de pas.
Ce phénomène est très dangereux.
Il provoque parfois la mort d'animaux dans les champs :
des vaches ou des moutons. En se tenant accroupi,
et les pieds serrés, les mains posées sur les genoux,
la différence de potentiel entre les pieds s'annule complètement
et le courant électrique ne passe plus dans l'organisme.
Il reste dans le sol.
Autre solution pour se protéger : la voiture.
Elle constitue une excellente protection contre la foudre.
La carrosserie métallique
forme une cage dite de Faraday.
L'électricité reste à la surface de la cage
et ne pénètre pas à l'intérieur.
C'est le même phénomène qui protège les passagers des avions quand ils traversent une zone orageuse.
Qui dit orage dit éclairs, mais aussi coups de tonnerre.
Les seconds font d'ailleurs souvent plus peur que les premiers.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui provoque ce bruit ?
Quand le courant passe, il provoque un échauffement.
L'air à cet endroit se dilate violemment.
Ce phénomène génère une onde sonore qui va se déplacer
jusqu'à nos oreilles en faisant vibrer les molécules d'air.
C'est ce qui est à l'origine du coup de tonnerre.
Au passage,
vous avez bien sûr remarqué que le son et l'image n'arrivent
jamais à vos yeux et à vos oreilles au même moment.
On voit d'abord l'éclair, puis on entend le tonnerre.
Si l'image et le son sont décalés, c'est
parce qu'ils ne se déplacent pas à la même vitesse.
Dans un air à quinze degrés et au niveau de la mer,
le son voyage à environ 340 mètres par seconde.
Il va beaucoup moins vite que la lumière qui,
elle, se déplace à 300000 kilomètres par seconde.
L'éclair et la détonation se produisent donc au même moment,
mais l'image se forme presque instantanément
sur la rétine de l'observateur, tandis que le son met parfois
plusieurs secondes pour atteindre ses oreilles,
le temps que la vibration des molécules d'air
se propage de proche en proche
jusqu'à ses tympans. Pour estimer la distance
qui nous sépare du lieu d'impact de la foudre,
il suffit donc de compter les secondes à partir du moment
où l'on voit l'éclair, puis de multiplier par 340.
Si la détonation parvient au bout de cinq secondes,
cela signifie que la foudre est tombée
5 X 340= 1700 mètres plus loin.
S'il s'écoule dix secondes, la foudre est
tombée à environ 3400 mètres.
Et pour savoir s'il faut se mettre à l'abri,
eh bien, il suffit de compter.
Au cas où de violents orages s'annoncent dans votre région,
n'hésitez pas
à vous rendre sur le site vigilance.météofrance.
Il vous indiquera tous les comportements à suivre.
Vous éloigner des arbres et des cours d'eau, par exemple.
Vous abriter dans un bâtiment en dur.
Ne pas utiliser votre téléphone ou d'autres appareils électriques.
Si ces orages s'accompagnent de très fortes précipitations,
rejoignez au plus vite un point haut ou abritez-vous à l'étage.
Enfin,
si vous circulez en voiture, ne vous engagez pas sur une route immergée,
même partiellement : le courant pourrait vous emporter.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
J'espère que vous avez compris qu'en cas d'orage,
le ciel ne risque pas de nous tomber sur la tête
et que vous avez bien mesuré les dangers.